what is going on everybody welcome to
yet another python three basics tutorial
video in this video what we're gonna be
talking about is how to get data from a
csv so how do we read data from a csv in
python so uh let's go ahead and get
started so a csv file is usually it's
kind of a popular file
type to be
dealing with any sort of data analysis
and stuff as you get into bigger data
data sets generally it's going to be
more of maybe a database format but csvs
are very popular and it's a pretty
common question how do we work with csv
files so let's go ahead and get started
so first of all there is a csv module
built into python so we just want to
import that so import csv lowercase
and just for the record csv stands for
comma separated variables
that's it
and actually even though it says csv and
that means comma separated variables we
can actually
use anything we could have a delay in
the comma is what's known as a delimiter
and we can have anything as a delimiter
we could have triple spaces tabs new
line
the letter x anything can be a delimiter
basically so
uh moving right along
let us
i have an example file here let me move
this over so this is the directory that
we're coding in right now this is the
script that i'm editing and here is an
example csv file so let me edit that
with notepad cancel
and here we have some sample data right
so we have some dates here a couple
numbers that just mean nothing and then
some colors okay
um so we got that in this file
and what we want to do is we want to
load that data into our python script so
the way that we're going to do that is
we're going to use with open
we haven't really talked much about this
with statement but we will get there
for now we'll just
just code it with me and whenever you're
opening files like this you can do this
to kind of iterate through a file
anyway uh with
open
[Music]
uh and then we're gonna do example.csv
as csv file
what do we wanna do well we're gonna say
reads we'll call us read csv
equals csv
reader
csv file
and then we're going to specify the
delimiter i just want to spell this
wrong as just commas okay so
basically what this is going to do is it
reads all of this csv data in so let me
just let's let's print out where we are
at the moment so read csv
uh we'll save and run that come over
here um well actually that's not gonna
work um
here's what we'll do instead so for a
row in
read csv
let's just print
uh
let's do that instead there we go um we
don't need to be printing this anymore
i'm just going to delete this
anyway and your output looks like this
okay so so that is the data from our
sample csv file first bit of data was
the date then a number then another
number then a color generally when
you're reading in data
it's going to read everything in as a
string so if you ever want it so keep
that in mind if you're going to be doing
math operations or something like that
on this data that you will want to
convert it to float into whatever
so let's close out of this
and so for row and read csv print row
now
uh maybe what we want to do is maybe
access some of that specific data so we
could say print you know row
zero that would be your date um we could
also print
and spell row right
print row
zero
[Music]
row
one stuff like that save and run it
and you see that we print you know um
you know just the date this is the date
and the first element
um and so on well the index of one
now uh
generally what you're going to want to
do when you read the csv into memory you
might be wanting to do something with
that csv
and you might even want to store each
column let's say in something so
instead let us do the following
up here say we just we're caring mostly
about dates and colors for now let's
just say dates equals and empty python
lists and colors equals an empty python
list
and then for row in read csv we're going
to do something we're going to say the
color
equals row and that was the fourth
element so index would that be three
and then date is the first element so
what index value would that be
zero now so we got date and color now we
want to do dates dot append because
we're gonna add to this list
uh date and then colors dot append this
color dog under me is going crazy
uh so now that we're done with that
after we iterate through all of this we
can do the following we can print
dates
print
colors
save and run it
and we come over here and now we have
two separate lists one list is all the
dates one list is all the colors
and each index corresponds to that you
know the corresponding
lists values right so this is kind of
why i was saying well dictionaries can
be more useful because you could store
the date as the key of the dictionary
and then
these values as the value of the
dictionary but we'll get there in a
little bit
and you can do all that with reading
files i just don't want to jump into
dictionaries and reading csvs all at
once uh but we'll we'll talk about that
later so now that you've done that let's
say
we're not using a dictionary
and we want to know
maybe we want to ask a question so let's
let's do this let's say
what
color
and what color is gonna be equal to
input
and then what color do you wish to know
the date of okay so this is going to ask
our user using raw input that we kind of
we've talked about raw input on one of
the earlier videos
it's going to ask our
user what color do we want to know the
date of and then we're going to say
codex for color index it's just a
meshing of words
hold x equals colors.index
what color so the user is going to type
in a color and then we're going to say
called x is the list
dot index of that color whatever color
we've typed in
and
that's in this list that we've populated
now
with codex
that gives us the index
number
of that color and then what we can do is
we can say the date of that color
equals dates
codex and that will return to the date
what date that index
of that color whatever we typed in is
okay
now we can print
the date of
what color
is the date
okay so
we can run this
even though we're going to know the
answer so green should correspond to 1 3
2014 so we could type uh green
whoops um
let's try that one last time and we're
going to talk about what just happened
in a second but green and it says the
date of green is 1 3 2014. now
just as an aside
whenever you have input like this or
maybe you're trying i'm trying to think
of some other circumstances besides you
know input or say you're like parsing
data or something like again with
sentiment analysis
you know great whether it's at the
beginning of a sentence or in the middle
of a sentence still kind of carries the
same i guess great's a bad one because
great could mean a pronoun but
um
anyway moving on uh
um trying to think of a better word but
a descriptive word let's say you know at
the beginning of a sentence whether it's
capitalized or not um doesn't really
necessarily matter unless it's all caps
or something but say like with green
green is green is green okay so whether
the first letter is capitalized or not
it does not matter so what you could do
is what color
equals
uh
you know this we could say codex what
color
and then dot lower what this is going to
do is it's going to make sure every
letter is lowercase so we can run this
one more time
[Music]
and we can do
green
and it still works okay the date of
green is one three four okay or 2014. so
that's how we can do
handle something like that but we'll get
to that uh uh that pro what we can do to
handle these sort of errors i think in
the next
video
um so anyway i think that's going to
conclude this video as far as reading
csv is because now we're going to jump
into error handling
in the next video so
if you guys have any questions or
comments on
reading from a csv storing it into some
lists
feel free to leave those questions or
comments below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time